[Music]
on this saturday night
a premier's power play to get help
the united states has millions of
vaccines
in freezers manitoba's desperate plea to
the american president circumventing
justin trudeau vaccine passports canada
prepares for the controversial documents
that could allow life to return to
pre-coveted times
plus the rise of hate crimes in america
over a conflict in the middle east and
new research shows
methane levels in the oil patch are
higher than what's being reported
[Music]
global national with robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us
manitoba's premier is making a direct
plea to the president of the united
states
the province is struggling with a surge
in kova 19 cases and the pandemic's
third wave has put manitoba's health
care system
on the brink of collapse brian pallister
believes joe biden can help
by sending more vaccines i'm advocating
for the united states
and the white house particularly to get
out of the way and let
states and provinces cooperate on
getting vaccines that are in freezers in
the united states up into canada into
arms
pallister says manitoba's neighbor north
dakota has an
excess of vaccines and is willing to
share but
isn't allowed to export them back in
march the biden administration did loan
canada more than a million doses of
astrazeneca
and this week the president confirmed
the u.s will share an additional 20
million doses of pfizer moderna and
johnson and johnson
with other countries over the next six
weeks it's not clear if canada is on the
list
right now manitoba is one of the coveted
19 hot spots in the country
and as marnie blunt explains a lack of
vaccines is not the only problem
facing the province they're images that
sparked
outrage online screen grabs of social
media posts circulating apparently
showing a graduation ceremony at springs
church in winnipeg
with large groups of people gathered
maskless very disappointing and
disturbing
and and just showed a sort of lack of
care for our community
in our province in this time of crisis
global news has not been able to verify
the photos or
whether the ceremony took place nor has
manitoba's premier but brian pallister
did say action may be taken if needed
i'll certainly look forward to finding
out what's actually happened before i
comment
but obviously if there are violations i
would expect that there would be
consequences for that and
it would be most unfortunate i think
it's frustrating
to a lot of manitobans particularly
heading into a long weekend where we're
not going to see our family and friends
it comes as manitoba put in place
tighter restrictions for the may long
weekend
as the province sees record numbers of
coven 19 cases
and intensive care units pushed to the
brink businesses are hurting families
are hurting relationships are suffering
we're all doing the best we can and
we've got some people out there
who choose not to do that last fall
springs church took
the manitoba government to court after
being fined for holding drive-in church
services
that were banned by the public health
orders at that time
this is still a problem and this is
still
not representing what i think that
christians and churches should be
representing in this time
and not what anyone should be doing amid
a state of emergency
they just clearly you know do not care
about the rules right now and
and chose and chose to do this thing
because it was more important than
than people dying in the hospital i
guess marty blunt global news
canada is making progress on the vaccine
front according to cobit tracker canada
just over 50 percent of the canadian
population has received at least one
dose
about four percent are fully vaccinated
and as more canadians receive a shot in
the arm
a growing number is also in favor of
using vaccine
passports to kick start the economy jeff
semple explains
in ontario the may long weekend is in
full swing
golf courses top a long list of
recreational reopenings
from basketball to tennis courts
ontario's outdoor amenities are back in
business
after a month-long lockdown it's great
that we're back
but while golfers are giddy many other
ontario businesses
remain shut some likely well into the
summer
even as a fast-growing number of
canadians are vaccinated
and that spurring calls for so-called
vaccine
passports regardless of how we feel or
think
we know that many countries are choosing
to impose
this proof of vaccination is fast
becoming a requirement for international
travel
the federal government just confirmed it
plans to adopt a certificate system for
canadian travelers
but exclusive ipsos polling for global
news finds a majority would like to
extend that system to
other activities around 74 percent of
canadians believe
vaccine passports should be required
from any visitors to long-term care
homes for example
67 percent are in favor for anyone
attending college or university
the same goes for indoor events like a
hockey game or theater
and 66 percent want proof of vaccination
for outdoor events
some jurisdictions are already doing
just that more fans in the ballpark here
michael tonight
and they're looking for something to
cheer about this week for the first time
in 20 months
parts of yankee stadium were full the
ball game open only to fans who could
prove
either with paper or their smartphone
that they're fully
vaccinated i think this is something
we're going to have to figure out as
canadian
quebec is already moving forward
providing both paper
and digital proof of vaccines and the
province says
businesses should be able to use these
certificates to make their workplaces
safer but in the u.s and canada
vaccine passports also face fierce
opposition
concerns over privacy and discrimination
including against those who are
medically unable to receive a vaccine
but that has to be balanced against the
fact that this is the solution of the
global pandemic and
you know if we want things to start
functioning normally people need to be
vaccinated as part of that
like in the u.s example experts here
expect vaccine passports to become
a patchwork adopted by some provinces
and businesses
sure to provide both a lightning rod for
covid controversy
and a ticket back to normal life
jeff sample global news toronto in
ontario starting tomorrow people between
the ages of 12 and 17 will be able to
book an appointment
to receive their first shot appointments
can be made through the provincial
booking system and call center
as well as select pharmacies health
canada has authorized the use of pfizer
for that age group as younger canadians
become eligible for the vaccine more and
more people are rolling up their sleeves
to get the shot
some canadians are worried about getting
the vaccine but a new ipsos poll done
exclusively for global news shows
most canadians will get the job as soon
as they can without any hesitation
jamie morocco reports just across the
road here and then head to the gentleman
with the
across canada people have been lining up
to get their covid19 vaccine
make a curve around it i'm scared and
excited at the same time
i was just waiting for this so far the
country has administered more than 20
million doses
a number that has shot up in recent
weeks says canadians itch for a return
to normal
frank graves has been researching this
trend and credits our falling hesitancy
rate for most people the imperative of
getting a vaccine and the fear of
missing out
is much higher so we're actually seeing
vaccine acceptance rates
rising in fact exclusive ipsos polling
for global news reveals
78 percent of those asked would agree to
take a coven 19 vaccine
as soon as they could without any
hesitation
up three points from last month when
you're seeing your friends your family
your parents your grandparents
being vaccinated you know and most of
them have had no
adverse effects you're more likely to
want to get the vaccine yourself our
rollout hasn't been without its issues
a stop on the johnson and johnson
vaccine in late april and a rollback of
the astrazeneca vaccine last week
but sabine vora miller who has been
working to dispel vaccine misinformation
says this hasn't deterred people
people's questions are being answered
and people are
a lot more comfortable given that we are
at a point where we've given
hundreds of millions of doses worldwide
proof is in the numbers
on friday canada surpassed the u.s in
percentage of population vaccinated with
at least one dose
i find it so cool that now that i could
finally get my vaccine
i could just feel a little better a
positive pandemic milestone experts say
get us one step closer to getting back
to normal before summer ends
tammy morocco global news toronto
yukon is moving forward with opening up
starting tuesday residents can gather in
crowds of up to 200 people for funerals
weddings and religious services
but they will still need to maintain
physical distancing the government says
it's able to lift health restrictions
because
76 percent of residents have received
their first shot
and approximately the same number is now
eligible for the second dose
fully vaccinated people won't need to
isolate for two weeks when they travel
to the territory
social bubbles can be bumped up to 20
plus bars and restaurants are back
to full capacity in the middle east
israel's ceasefire with hamas appears to
be holding for a second day
but it could take years for traumatized
civilians to rebuild their lives
new footage shows the scale of the
destruction israeli airstrikes inflicted
on neighborhoods in gaza
officials there estimate more than 2 000
homes were destroyed in the 11-day
assault
and 15 000 more were damaged schools
medical centers and vital infrastructure
also suffered damage
a convoy of treks carrying food aid is
arriving in gaza from egypt
that country helped broker the truce its
mediators held more discussions with
israeli and palestinian officials today
aiming to ensure the calm is maintained
that conflict in the middle east has led
to an alarming rise in attacks on jewish
people
in the united states it's happening in
two forms
vicious violence and online vitriol
jennifer johnson has the story and a
warning
some of the images are disturbing
violence and chaos in new york's times
square
after someone in a pro-palestinian
caravan through fireworks
into a crowd of pro-israel supporters as
the crowd scatters this video captures
the moment 29 year old joseph borgen was
viciously attacked
also i'm surrounded by like a whole mob
crowd of people
they proceeded to you know obviously
assault me beat me
kick me punch me hit me with crutches
the man seen in the video carrying a
crutch has been charged with a hate
crime
new york police are searching for other
suspects borgin says the attackers
yelled anti-semitic slurs at him
you're a dirty jew we're going to kill
you tensions are rising across
america following almost two weeks of
bloodshed in the middle east
and it's not just physical attacks
anti-semitic comments are flooding
social media too
we are seeing a level of anti-semitism
related to the conflict in the middle
east that is
beyond quantifiable in los angeles
restaurant patrons were pelted with
glass bottles
and attacked by people waving
palestinian flags synagogues are also
being targeted
a swastika was carved in the glass of
the synagogue in utah a brick was thrown
into the window of another in arizona
active hatred happened to us it feels
like a real
shattering tempers are flaring on both
sides
members of the chicago coalition for
justice in palestine flooded the streets
demanding congress put a hold on sales
of u.s weapons to israel
but in other places israeli supporters
are blasting hamas for its actions
they have been keeping the people of
gaza
hostage shooting missiles at the
israeli civilians and they don't care
who these bombs are falling on
police in new york los angeles and other
cities say they are stepping up patrols
to try and prevent more attacks as anger
from the middle east
spills over to america jennifer johnson
global news
washington the canadian forces snowbirds
are preparing for a summer flying season
that no one was sure would come
the return to the skies follows a somber
anniversary
one year ago a crash in kamloops claimed
the life of snowbirds captain
jennifer casey as paul johnson reports
the sight of the planes is a sign that
getting back to normal
is on the horizon here's a hopeful sign
that we're headed for a return
to something like normal
canada's snow birds are back in the air
we're always
always happy to be back in comox cfb
comox is where the snowbirds
traditionally train every spring
putting the finishing touches on their
performance for the summer air show
season
while there's still a lot of uncertainty
surrounding pandemic restrictions
as of this week the snowbirds have a
19-day
schedule of air shows and flyovers
across north america
this year is going to be a special year
like last year as well
a year ago it was a much different
picture
their mission to boost the morale of
canadians in the early lockdowns
ended in tragedy when a jet crashed in
kamloops
killing jen casey their public affairs
officer
the planes were grounded air shows
everywhere were canceled
and many wondered would the snowbirds
ever return
we still plan on flying and showing the
population of canada how
awesome the team is and how awesome they
are
few countries the size of canada have
consistently fielded a demonstration
team like the snowbirds who are
typically
crowd favorites at air shows with their
nine jet
aerial ballet and if that's not an
achievement
consider the airplane itself a
canadian-built jet
that they've kept flying for 50 years
now
so watch the skies this summer for the
return
of a national icon paul johnson global
news
coming up is international travel on the
horizon
it's the may long weekend and so many
canadians are stuck at home
it's been a long year with little to no
travel so when will ottawa open up the
international border
our mercedes stephenson put that
question to the liberal government
mercedes robin intergovernmental affairs
minister dominic leblanc says
discussions are ongoing with the airline
sector
and international partners about how and
when
international borders will be opened up
one key issue
options for international vaccine
certification
or so-called vaccine passports as that
gets sorted leblanc says the government
will also be watching for certain
benchmarks
to determine when international travel
is safe
those decisions will be governed by what
public health advice we get
from experts from doctors and scientists
in canada they're looking at things like
obviously the covid case count the
positivity
rates for incoming travelers they're
looking at the stress or
capacities of health care systems and
obviously mercedes vaccination
rates are a critical piece of that
calculation
leblanc wouldn't give a specific
timeline on when he thinks canadians
will see those benchmarks simply saying
we're just not there yet
and with a potential election in the
coming months i also asked minister
leblanc about when
he expects an announcement on the
governor general's replacement
a potential key to calling an election
canada has been without
a permanent head of state for more than
four months
leblanc says a committee should give the
prime minister a short list of
candidates
very soon there are committee mercedes
won't give the prime minister only one
name
we're going to give him a short list of
names uh he'll
he'll have a number of names from which
we think an outstanding uh canadian can
be chosen to serve
in that role it's it's going to be a
list of more than one and less than 10.
leblanc said that he expects the
governor general's selection process
to be weeks more but not months so we
should have an answer soon
robin mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes
still ahead methane miscalculations is
canada's climate strategy based on the
wrong figures
one week after touching down china's
first mars rover has left its station to
explore the planet
this makes china the first country to
orbit land and rove on mars
in its inaugural mission it's the second
nation after the u.s to land a rover on
the red planet
it's remote controlled solar powered and
set to study the surface
and atmosphere of mars meanwhile
this planet is facing a serious threat
methane gas
even though we can't see it or smell it
it's considered a potent
greenhouse gas and a new report suggests
more methane is leaking from canada's
oil patch than previously believed
as ross lord explains our country's
climate strategy
may be based on bad estimates
cutting methane emissions is considered
an important part of canada's fight
against climate change
so researchers say it's important to
establish how much of the harmful
greenhouse gas is escaping from oil and
gas developments
but new findings from a study led by
nova scotia researcher caitlin mckay
suggests calculations have been fuzzy
it's becoming clearer that
there are some issues that need to be
worked on the federal government has
promised to cut methane emissions from
oil and gas
40 to 45 below 2012 levels
by the year 2025. but the new research
suggests
the government's targets are based on
inaccurate estimates for how much
methane is currently leaking
the report says actual emissions range
from equivalent
to substantially higher likely exceeding
government estimates by a factor of 1.5
or 50 percent more environmentalists
say the findings are important methane
makes up
about 15 of canada's
greenhouse gas emissions now this
research is telling us it's higher than
that as a result mckay says
more work is needed to stifle methane
based on
our study it seems as though that we
need to be reducing
more emissions than previously estimated
her team's findings are based on 6600
measurements
providing a larger body of evidence than
government estimates
data was collected while driving through
oil and gas installations
using laser technology to analyze the
methane
funding partners include industry
through the petroleum technology
alliance
oil and gas developers have an incentive
to take part they could
qualify for federal funding that pays
them for finding ways to meet methane
regulations
mckay hopes the government uses her
team's findings to update the extent of
canada's methane problem
as it figures out how to fix it ross
lord global news
halifax up next did a bc woman drown
or was she murdered what her husband has
to say about the case
it has been nearly five years since a bc
woman died while boating with her
husband
there have since been a series of
dramatic developments raising questions
about whether arlene westervelt drowned
or was murdered global's jules knox has
been investigating and has an exclusive
interview
with the victim's husband jules
robin bert westervelt has always claimed
that his wife's death was an accident
after the couple's canoe tipped and
arlene went missing on june 26
2016. rcmp pulled her body out of
okanogan lake the next day
and initially believed it was an
accident since then it's been
one plot twist after another finally
in 2019 bert westervelt was charged with
killing his wife
and then last summer that charge was
suddenly stayed
now burt westerveld is publicly speaking
out for the first time since his wife's
death
you saw the case that was built against
you
what stood out to you and that why would
they charge you
that's a good question
that's a good question i don't i don't
know
i still to this day don't know how it
got this far
so your story changed in the days that
followed arlene's death
do you understand why that might raise
suspicion
yes i do and you know i apparently
that's
a large part as to the reason why i was
arrested
did you kill your wife
sorry did you kill your wife no god no
bert westerville wouldn't answer all of
our questions on the advice of his
lawyer
but he did have laws to say about the
case including the stormy relationship
with his in-laws that he believes
contributed to his arrest and we have
new details that suggest
the investigation into arlene
westervelt's death may have been doomed
from the start
robin all right thanks for that jules
and you can watch the full story tonight
at 7 p.m on the new reality
right here on global and that is global
national for this saturday night
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is a
view of the lake
in alberta's elk island national park
thank you for watching please enjoy this
long weekend safely and i'll see you
back here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you